UFC fighter is into autoerotic fixation
and when some guy takes his back rather
than trying to get out of and he starts
[__] rubbing one out is he tapping
now he's jerking
off genius way to get out of the
hold Conor McGregor immediately let go
of that rear naked Choice the choke he
got him and he started jerking off
everything right when the bell rings you
start running at him [__] jerking
on all all your [__] muscle memory is
just gone and in that moment you do the
flying
knee and then they would immediately
make it illegal and then and it would be
it would be fck it would be named after
you Paul Paul ver rule what's the Paul
ver rule you can't run out a guy jerking
off to begin it to to [__] with his head
wait he did that yeah dude if I saw guy
jerking off a UFC fight against me I'd
be like dude you win touch your dick
D I'd be I'd be right up and over the
fence